this morning walking my my dog
and thinking about uh
liking this next film
and all the
talk about energy and
center circle and
what i was going to talk to you about
i decided i'll let off the lead let have
a good run we're in a quiet space
and i noticed that as i'm thinking i'm
looking down
missing out on the beauty of the fields
the yellow in the fields
the waving of the corners it blows in
the wind
but it was more important that i thought
about how i was going to talk about this
film
it was to me
i didn't realize that me and
my dog had come quite a distance apart
until i heard a run by me
i could hear her coming
a little bit like a horse coming
and i could hear her when she went past
me
and i realized that the mass
that she was placing in her feet into
the ground
is something that we
we all strive for you know aikido at our
early stages
the
that made me think
oh i haven't thought about how i'm
actually walking
and then i realized well i don't need to
think how i'm walking because i'm just
walking and actually enjoying the walk
apart from my head
down so i decided to look up
so that i could see the beauty
and it's then harder to concentrate on
what i wanted to talk to you about
so by being distracted easily
can make us so that we miss the point
on the
on the recent film
talking about
looking along the row
working out who you think that um
your zanshi and your awareness
is with those different people
it can be to your advantage
if you just work with those rather than
looking longer and um why can't i
connect with that person i can't it's a
little bit like
oh i can't get the technique can i do it
again what can i do again
better to work with those that you think
oh why am i
perhaps
we're
positive and negative perhaps we're two
positives and you know you can make it
as complicated as you want for your own
mind but search
search it
but just like as i but my advice is just
like i was walking
and didn't have to think about my
walking heavy or light
until i heard my dog remind me
that she's just a natural
living creature that
is
very connected with the earth
because she's not thinking like a human
and complicating things
so
connect with the people
if you can bow to them and get them as a
partner
how long can you hold that
connection for
just like lifting my head up and trying
to look in the fields
by watching them you start watching your
eyes
and you lose the connection
if you've got your eyes open
and yet with your head down
you can think
try to
even by seeing
switch your eyes off
and go into
sensing
so if they bring their hand up for i'm
going to say for yokomanuchi or
shomonuchiki or whatever they do
see if you can actually feel it inside
did you you might not
understand at this stage how you can
feel and raise their hand
but if you can if you can feel when they
let raise their hand
in some way
did it draw like a line inside you
up your chest across your body
in your
forehead did you did you actually feel
the lift of their arm
inside yourself
nano
sheen he talks about
i can feel the energy
and when he does
as i do yoga
and tai chi
they're much more slower and much more
subtle
and if you actually start working on a
slower pace
i remember cytosinte saying i want you
to work slower
so that you can get it accurate but you
can also
feel
what you're doing better
so you may like
in one of the earlier films i said about
the bouncing
that i see students do after after
they've done a technique to ground
themselves with the match
you can
study
can or every time you ask them it's
their turn to attack whatever the
technique china anchor as they come
forward can you actually feel them come
forward
can you feel their presence
coming forward
try to search for that so when you're
looking at them
switch your receptors off with your
seeing receptors
and work on your sensing receptors
oh i think i felt a breeze
you might start looking is there any
windows or doors open
yes you can go that stream if you feel
that you need to
and unlike
me i've done that for the period
and when you see there's no doors or
windows open you're in a sealed confined
sports or a room and nobody calls the
draft
around you
you stop keep
it's like criticizing yourself wanting
answers why you felt it
the certainly you can accept
that you sense that
then your
your senses are starting to work
so you can decide taste smell sound
you know you can decide what sensing you
want
so you're looking at them
this is the exercise in this film you're
looking at them let's say they're coming
for yo community
you're trying to feel a sensing
somewhere within your body perhaps you
lift your arms momentarily afterwards
if you lift your arm when they lift
their arm that's a mechanical thing and
that's like
holding your head down and then when
looking up
you've lost the depth of your thought
you've transferred by lifting your arm
when they lift their arm you've
transferred
from sensing to mechanical
and that's
done then through body memory
and if you lift every time they lift
because your timing is good
and you've worked out oh i can lift
exactly when they lift when they lift
all it lifts my arm
that's your body memory
going through the stages of knowing
um
how to get better timing
and this may be a stage that you've got
to go through before you go to the stage
that i'm talking about
it's up to each individual to
practice and train their own
depth
so in the end when you feel this feeling
income
within you and you don't question
anymore
as as the motion starts of sensing the
arm will come up you don't even have to
think about where it is
the same as the atemi you know if their
temmie comes in at first i've got to
think about their tummy coming in in
there that terry comes in and you think
oh
it was as if
something somebody instructed me to do
that without me even knowing i was going
to do it
i hope this is all making sense to you
and um
it's not boring you or
making things more complicated
it's very we are a very complex piece of
equipment the human being very complex
i don't know i don't suppose even the
most
top people in the world who study the
human race
in all the different
formats that uh
the doctrines
that they've had masters degrees and
everything
they'll only specialize
in a field a certain field
why do we have a whole brain if we're
only using a part of it
well perhaps we can use a little bit
more of our brain
by
searching out our individual
personalities
once you get to this stage or stages
and you start to work not on technical
anymore
but on
inspiration
in other words what you're given
you get
don't try to reinvent the wheel the
wheel works perfectly okay until we have
flying cars and the wheels great
but from the beginnings of the wheel
formosan see what he gave us and
psychosis he gave us the technical and a
lot of other masters in the world have
given us the technical
but very few have given us the spiritual
kojita
um
he was about the only one i know who
talked more about
keen daily life
you know
how to weigh underside your arm and how
to make your body heavy
and
things that you could do with your mind
rather than
just your body
we've got a lot to explore
and we can only do it if we're intrigued
or want to be bothered to
look at these different
formats that we can add into our own
aikido
so if my body allows me to keep going
um
in a reasonable way of flexibility
that i hope to still be able to reach
an individuality i have an individuality
now
the same as all of us
but somebody might watch my technical
style and say oh yes i can see he was a
student of psychology
some have even said oh dear sensei
wouldn't be happy if they saw you doing
that
well that's fine i'm still a student and
i'm still trying my best
and even though sensei didn't get it
right all the time nor did cytosensei so
that he told me
so i can't find that uniqueness
because i'm a human being and so are you
but what we can do is we can start to
form our own style
within the forms of the techniques that
we've been given
if we start working on the energy side
and the sensing side
these techniques
will go from a handful
to limitless
because that's what osensi called the
word takamusu
he said
technique do not worry about doing
technique a technique will be born
when it's needed
and
i believe that this talking about energy
sensing and finding
how
things that you can't see
but you can sense
start
putting them in to your mix
of aikido
and you will start to become an
individual teacher and you will start to
perhaps shorten the techniques
making them so that
you've already felt the flow far before
the technique was started
therefore you can shorten it because
there is no time limit anymore there is
no
complete technique anymore the only
technique is
did it work in the shortest possible way
were you connected as one with yours
with your
partner your attacker
and no longer an individual you are the
puppet
of the other person because you are the
other person
because they've
timed you
by you being connected
by your senses from the moment they
approached
the moment you spotted them
then blending and whatever your body
is physically capable of doing
will do a form of technique
it may not be a complete one that you
would see in a book
there'll be a part of it there'll be a
shape of it
at my level i've said before everything
now is becoming spiral
and those techniques that aren't spiral
i question why
it must be down to me not seeing the
smile
okay
please always send in questions
without questions
how will we ever know the answers or how
will it tax
each of us
to
look deeper find the answers
it's for the future
of
a senses aikido
that i'm interested in as well as the
future of my own aikido
the things that i still haven't learned
i remember psycho sent you sound once
when the person doesn't progress
it's because they're in a like a stepped
scale with pegs in
and they get to a certain level
and they're the only person who can pull
out the pig and raise it to a higher
hole
i think it's a very good way of
explaining it
and i go sometimes for years with my peg
in a certain hole
and then i have a glimmer of light but
unless i search it
unless i really look
and turn it over upside down think of
everything go outside the box
then what chance have i got of pulling
that peg out and raising it
to a higher
level
in hopes that there's more
levels above the one i've reached
and with your help i hope we will all
find
a way of pulling pegs out and raising
them
thank you for listening